[Music]
so uh here at the Pete home show we have
some of the best fans in the world
obviously and a couple weeks ago we
asked some of the ones that might be
artistically inclined to submit fan art
I honestly wasn't sure if anyone would
do it but you did which is amazing so
I'm actually going to show some of it
now you want to see some fan
art uh what do we got here first this is
the first one
uh okay that's me as a child's nightmare
that's a fun one
next uh we got this one okay not a
flattering
one looks like the before Nathan Lane
kind of picture it's kind of scary
here's another one uh oh
balloons somebody yeah somebody made me
out of balloons it's it's nice to know
that somewhere I'm in someone's attic
just slowly
deflating uh next what do we got here
that oh
yeah that's yeah you know that's me
saying fantastic into a stripper's butt
which is a true story there's a stripper
out there telling the story I was
bending over but I think he said
fantastic and finally uh we got
okay yeah I got two words about this one
I
[Music]
like